has it sunk in yet  not yet  [Laughter]  i think it's gonna take a while  you were so emotional and so excited you  had that whole room captivated what was  that moment like for you  know  [Music]  [Music]  the awards itself is given to you by so  many amazing and talented actors and i  felt that was very special and i really  wanted to express my gratitude as a fan  of everybody there but also as someone  who's just starting out in this path  and i especially wanted to express all  of my love and thanks to all the support  i got from all my seasoned actors and  actresses who were part of the cast i  love that did you get to meet rhys  witherspoon no not yet  it was turkey i had so many things to do  i had to pretend ore so i couldn't  i couldn't go to the seat  so i was at the green room  but i'm at  streep and  kate blanchett oh my gosh well that's a  win congratulations to you all  congratulations on a wonderful night oh  have a fun time  yes we'll do